one of the things I find very
fascinating about Americans is they will
watch bad content if it's easy and and
if Hollywood and those guys don't get
their movies on the internet people are
just gonna create generate and watch the
content and it's no different if you
think about TV when TV came into 50s
Hollywood --nt wouldn't let movies or
actors go on TV so what a TV do they
created the Howdy Doody or the farm
report always sort of bad bad content
and we all watched it eyeballs on TV
drove an advertising that drove content
to the TVs you're seeing the same thing
play out right in front of our eyes on
internet blu-ray versus HD yeah well
maybe blu-ray want I know but it's it's
a sum it's it's a meaningless victory
because if you look at the CES show
there was devices everywhere and all
those devices were designed to enable
you to move and share content
electronically and they all had storage
device none of them had physical
distribution of content be honest I was
pretty excited fact that people are now
trying to pull the DVD players out of
these pcs and notebooks because guess
what people are gonna download
everything and that when a download
world really impacts eating apples got
the best system you know it doesn't mean
it has to always be right now they're
the ones that managed to put the
software the hardware and the content
together in a package really what I
think a lot of Apple is doing it's about
it's about a system that allows you to
download videos download content move it
from a PC to a notebook to it - III
video or to a TV set and again I think
this gets bigger and bigger a billion
blogs a billion video blogs were
downloaded in the US alone last what
what forecast am I gonna say for 2008
whether we're every session uh you know
I don't know I mean you know I make this
common in the disk drive business you
know you go a day without food a day
without water a day without sex but you
know we can't go a day without
rationalizing something and so I'll give
you my rationalization is that it's an
election year
and I cannot believe that we're not
going to just pump money into this
economy like crazy because it's an
election year no one's going to run a
November on recession that said be
honest we're not seeing it now our
business is great
internationally both Europe and Asia is
very very strong
you know you know 70% of our shipments
go there but we're not even seen the US
we got phenomenon a man right now from
our customer set so again I guess if you
get the 2008 from me it's it's you know
I'm gonna count on an election year
government
you